so i got a little surprise in the mail a
little while ago and when i got it i saw
the last 10 years of my life flash
before my eyes i got the official
certificate i got the small stamp and
the big stamp and i also got the cool
stamp and when i opened the box it was
pretty uh pretty anticlimactic
but i have been working towards this
moment for the past 10 years so today i
thought i'd reflect on my journey to
become a licensed architect and share
some of the life lessons i've learned
we'll cover everything from education to
career to youtube to money
and i'm also going to try to answer some
common questions that i get from you
guys this video is sponsored by
grammarly we'll talk about them later
and this video is gonna be a little bit
longer than usual i mean i am gonna be
covering the past 10 years of my life so
grab a cup of tea and get cozy
[Music]
so let's start all the way back back to
when i was in high school i actually had
no idea what i wanted to study when i
was in high school i was interested in a
bunch of different things but nothing
really in particular
so i was going to apply to
business school arts and sciences and
just see what happened but i did really
really love
painting and at my high school we had
this art room that we could use whenever
we wanted to
so i used to go in there and paint
during my free time and after school and
one day i was talking to one of our
student teachers megan
and she was like
you should apply to architecture school
and i
really didn't know anything about
architecture back then
but the more i looked into it it sounded
pretty interesting and well i also
wanted to try moving to a different city
and i saw that toronto had a couple of
architecture schools
so i decided to put together a portfolio
and i ended up getting into ryerson
university
and i actually really ended up enjoying
architecture i get so many questions
from i think those of you probably still
in high school about like how do i know
uh what to study in university
how do i know if i'm going to be any
good at architecture
and i guess the lesson i want to give
you here is
just kind of trust in serendipity and
plant the seeds of those serendipitous
encounters the fact that this student
teacher
happened to be at our school that week
and that she just happened to notice me
doing these paintings you could say it's
like random luck but according to
stephen johnson
serendipity
yes it needs unlikely collisions and
discoveries but it also needs something
to anchor those discoveries and if i
hadn't been sitting in the art room
making these paintings megan probably
would have never noticed that i might be
interested in architecture and
i think it's really good to plan out
your life
but when something happens like
something unexpected comes along that
pulls your interest
don't be so quick to dismiss it because
it wasn't a part of your original plan
this is also a response to another very
common question i get which is
um oh i like drawing and math so
do you think i'm gonna like architecture
first of all i
i don't know i can't tell you what to do
but
you know you can think about this
question your whole life
but
i have so many friends and like cousins
who thought they were gonna be doctors
and then they went to medical school and
they hated it and they dropped out
because in the end you can stress out
about this and you can take personality
tests and all that but in the end you
really don't know what you're gonna like
until you try it
so i got into architecture school and i
moved to toronto by myself when i was
just 18 years old and it was all very
exciting and
also very scary but mostly very exciting
and
i think most first-year students will
experience something similar to this
for me it was kind of like seeing the
world for the first time i think i was
always a very sensitive kid and i always
appreciated beauty but architecture
it was just the first time i i learned
why things are beautiful
and you know it is pretty mind-blowing
you you learn that every object and
every space you've come across has
meaning and there's like poetry behind
it
and there's like intent behind concrete
or stone or wood
and like learning about the idea of
phenomenology and it's all kind of like
all of a sudden you have this new
language and
now you understand and you can express
the world in a completely different way
so
yeah first year was very exciting but
my
excitement did not really translate into
good projects or good grades i was
actually pretty behind a lot of the
other students because a lot of them
actually knew that they wanted to go
into architecture pretty early on
and so when they were in high school
they were taking like drafting classes
and some of them already knew how to use
autocad and like 3d modeling
they didn't they knew what a plan and
section was which i didn't
needless to say
my grades were not
the best i kind of had to learn like all
of this new software on my free time and
it took me a painfully long time to do
things and i was just very lost and
confused and i had so many moments where
i really really wanted to drop out but
even when i thought it was never gonna
get better and even when i thought i was
like the worst worst worst student ever
things did start to take a turn
and i think the lesson here is
pain and reflection equals growth this
is something i learned from the book
principles by ray dalio if you don't
know him he's the founder of like the
biggest hedge fund in the world
bridgewater and with like 150 billion
dollars in assets and he basically
attributes his success to being able to
look at the world in terms of systems
and principles and one of these
principles is
yeah pain plus reflection
equals progress for me too
the first couple of years were really
really painful
but
when i look back in terms of my growth
trajectory i think that my first year
alone was probably the year when i
experienced a massive amount of growth
and when i compare that to times in my
life where i was kind of coasting that's
i think when i grew the least because i
was the least challenged
and i was the least satisfied with my
life and my work and during that time
actually like
i'm someone who really values personal
growth so i spent a lot of time reading
like self-development books but
reading or listening to podcasts it's
not a painful experience and
the lessons they never really
changed me in a big way but
struggling alone isn't gonna get you
that far
i've seen lots of students who struggle
from day one all the way to their fourth
sixth
like seventh year of school and i think
a lot of it has to do with this very
unhelpful advice which is practice makes
perfect practice doesn't make perfect
perfect practice makes perfect every
time you do something you should be
reflecting on how you can do that thing
better and faster and more efficiently
because the way you get better is not to
work harder
but to build a system to do that thing
better so as you're struggling
constantly be thinking about how can i
do this thing better so back to my
journey so after i finished my
bachelor's i took a year off i moved
back to vancouver
and i worked at a boutique firm in
gastown it was a really good experience
but for the most part
it was pretty terrifying
i kind of got thrown in the deep end and
on my very first month like i had to go
meet a client and i was in charge of
doing like a permit set
like hello
what is a permit i pretty much didn't
understand anything about the process or
like the building code and it was a
pretty big struggle and one day i
realized
that
i had made a pretty
pretty
big mistake
when i was submitting a permit that
potentially delayed the client from
opening his restaurant for like a couple
of months um and that night and actually
that entire week i really i couldn't
sleep at all because i was so scared and
i thought we were gonna get into a
lawsuit
but
when the client came in for a meeting
um
seriously like to my utter surprise the
principal just
talked it over with him and
it was all
okay somehow so that taught me a pretty
big lesson which was that first of all
things that feel monumental to you in
the moment
it can be relatively small to other
people especially when you're just
starting out when you talk to more
senior people who've been around for for
longer
you will very quickly realize that
they've come across bigger and
much much much worse mistakes mistakes
are just opportunities to learn
it's a part of the job
and you just learn from it and you just
move on and secondly
and this is a big one
so sometimes it's about how you phrase
it when you realize that you made a
mistake think for a second about how you
want to communicate that and how you can
solve the problem so before when i make
a mistake i would get super super super
stressed out and just super scared and
be like holy cow this happened and this
happened and this happened and oh my god
i'm so so so sorry please forgive me
but um people walk around with their own
mistakes and their own stress and they
don't need that extra baggage in their
lives and if you want to be valuable
you want to be a problem solver not a
problem creator i found it's best to
present the facts objectively and always
propose a solution like this and this
and this happened but we can do this and
this and that's much more proactive and
you're not just relying on other people
to
solve the problem for you and it also
gets your head thinking in a way that in
the future you probably will not make
this mistake again but if you have to
relay this information in an email it
does add another layer of difficulty
which is why tools like grammarly can be
really really helpful grammarly is an
all-in-one writing tool that helps you
communicate your ideas clearly and
effectively by giving you comprehensive
feedback across different platforms
grammarly does have a free version with
basic grammar and spelling suggestions
but upgrading to their premium version
will actually save you so much time with
their features like tone transforms full
sentence rewrite features
which help you write more clearly by
suggesting different words or
repositioning words and also with their
tone detectors which has been super
helpful for me because sometimes when
you're just trying to get stuff done you
might not realize that you sound like an
and we're in the business of
relationships so these things really do
matter grammarly is free to download and
it's easy to integrate with your
everyday tools like gmail or google docs
just the other day i was getting
pushback from one of our consultants
basically telling us that they weren't
gonna do any more work because it was
outside of their scope and i basically
had to tell them that
yeah
you're right but
we reduced your work and a lot of other
areas plus you were a month late on
delivering your work
so it would be great if you completed
the work please and thank you and
grammarly really helped me craft this
email in a way that was concise
professional and stern and because
navigating these tricky situations are a
really big part of an architect's job
having the writing assistant can save
you so much time get through those
emails quicker by keeping it concise and
confident
and in the right tone with grammarly go
to grammarly.com dammy to sign up for a
free account and get 20 off grammarly
premium to help you work more
efficiently so back to my journey
so that experience working for this firm
after my bachelor's was such an eye
opener for me and i i couldn't believe
that after four years of school i was
still such a snowflake
and i really felt like i had to become
an architect as fast as possible and
i just felt really impatient so i went
right back to my masters and here i kind
of want to try to answer the question of
is a university education worth it so
the beginning of my master's
was actually a little bit disappointing
i
wanted to learn more about working in
the field
but there were only a few courses that
actually talked about the practice of
architecture but it did eventually get
better and looking back my masters was
probably the most rewarding and
intellectually stimulating times of my
life because basically day in and day
out you get to work on a topic that
you're interested in and with constant
feedback from professors who have an
incredible depth of knowledge in this
area and
you might not be getting practical hard
skills like learning revit or spec
writing but you're learning all of these
meta skills like writing designing
researching presenting and
learning to learn that's a pretty big
one that you can
bring all of these skills into
a lot of other aspects of your life and
not just into architecture and i think
these skills have
helped me start my youtube channel
it's helped me build an audience
and if you look at a lot of the top
architects their skills aren't revit or
spec writing
it's architects who can communicate
their value and communicate something
that's very
elusive into something tangible you have
to remember that lots of people
invest time and money for hard skills i
mean it makes sense right they're
they're typically directly employable
and usually it's directly attached to a
monetary value but hard skills are
actually kind of temporary with changes
in technology and the industry while
meta skills are actually permanent
skills that's going to make you more
adaptable and more resilient wherever
you go so one lesson from this would be
invest in your math skills as much as
your heart skills but
i am still not answering the question of
is a university education worth it
because yeah you're right if you wanted
to you could get these meta skills by
doing an online course or or even from
working for a firm right but
if you want to be an architect right now
these are hard requirements you can see
my video where i describe the
step-by-step process to become a
licensed architect and i think sometimes
because it's a hard requirement it's
really easy to fall into the trap of
thinking that this is just something you
have to get through and i think that
mindset can hinder you from fully taking
advantage of your education i think it's
a really subtle shift in mindset but
when you
think about your education as a
long-term goal and a long-term
investment in yourself
you're going to be asking more questions
you're going to be actively engaging
your profs and you're gonna be
reflecting on your process and like
trying to improve whenever you make a
mistake trying to understand why you got
a bad grade and trying to figure out why
certain things worked and like why
certain things didn't work and if
there's one thing we should be investing
in
it is our education and so the lesson
from this would be see education as a
long-term investment in yourself not a
requirement
and use this time to start building
systems for your workflow so that i can
benefit you down the road okay so i'm
officially through the school phase of
my life
but if you have any other questions
about that feel free to ask me in the
comments and i'll make sure to answer
them how do i decide what firm to work
for so once i finished my masters i felt
like i still didn't really know anything
about being an architect so my goal was
to fill in those gaps in my knowledge as
fast as possible and i really wanted to
learn how to navigate around code and
zoning i wanted to learn how to build
and the construction process
and how to work with contractors and
clients and i also wanted to learn how
an architecture business works and
basically all the things that were
covered in like one course in school
and just not nearly nearly nearly enough
to understand the whole process um so i
applied to several firms
and i got an offer from two firms um one
of them was a larger firm with bigger
projects and they offered me not a lot
but a little bit a little bit more money
which was a lot for me at that time
and the other firm was a smaller firm
only three people with smaller projects
and they were kind of i guess total
opposite
and as a young grad i was obviously more
tempted to take the job from the larger
firm you know they have more people they
have more resources and it's a little
cooler it's a little fancier but i just
asked around a lot from some of the
older grads
and i ended up taking the job from the
smaller firm for a little bit less money
and one of the deciding factors was
actually during the interview at the
small firm
one of the partners he couldn't make it
and so
there was an intern that actually took
part in the interview process which kind
of made an impression on me
he said both the partners are really
invested in is learning and there's
really good work-life balance and they
really help you get your hours so i
ended up going there and luckily it
turned out to be a good fit and i know
that i'm lucky that this doesn't happen
all the time i and i learned so much
during my three years there
and they really helped me get my
architecture license within three years
which is like pretty much the shortest
amount of time you can take which
obviously results in
ta-da more money
this lesson is it responds to another
common question which is how do i know
what type of firm i should work for and
it's actually a really great question
and something you should give a bit of
thought to
because early in your career
the firm that you work at it is gonna
kind of shape you like who you become as
an architect and the trajectory of your
career so
my advice here would be
try to follow people
not money or companies or
not even projects and let me elaborate
don't follow money because your starting
salary is gonna be relatively minuscule
wherever you go
so in the grander scheme of things that
extra few grand isn't really going to
make a monumental impact in your life
you want to invest in your growth
and you want to grow faster and try to
get that license early on because you're
going to be able to contribute more to a
firm and eventually have a much more
meaningful increase in your income over
the years and
when i say don't follow companies or
even
projects i'm not saying like don't go
for a high quality firm because you
should like you
are gonna be exposed to better processes
and better projects
and it's gonna give you a better
portfolio but i say this because i know
tons of people who worked five to ten
years
just doing schematic design um dd for a
big company and over that time span like
you could have gotten licensed and you
know the firm in the end is a business
and it's easier for them to keep you in
one phase of a project so no matter how
many cool projects you're working on if
you're firm doesn't have the culture of
mentoring
and
if they're not invested in your growth
it can be tough to grow as an architect
so you want to try to find a balance but
even though i had this great learning
environment the process of becoming an
architect was actually really tough and
i came pretty close to quitting several
times it was tough and being an intern
you don't always get to do the most fun
stuff and the process of collecting
hours and writing exams and
all that was insanely insanely insanely
tedious and that's why i have a lot of
sympathy for for interns and also just
like the general negativity around the
profession like if you don't believe me
just check any online architecture form
it's terrible but at some point in this
journey i read grit by angela duckworth
which kind of gave me a totally new
perspective on things and i i would
highly highly highly recommend this book
for all of you if you haven't read it
she says enthusiasm is common and
endurance is rare and i think it's
really easy to say okay this is too hard
i'm done with this thing and i'm gonna
go to this new shiny thing but she says
true happiness and fulfillment comes
from getting really good at something
and slowly becoming an expert in things
learning new things is hard
and making mistakes is really hard and
being an intern and working on an intern
salary that's really hard it was really
hard for me
but once you gain more experience
things become easier and for me i really
started to love my job so this is the
next lesson which is like stay
persistent and don't give up and try to
tune out the negativity because i find
that in general unhappy people are the
most vocal and they're the ones who
complain the most well in general like
happy and satisfied people you know just
continue living their lives so
a little while after i finished my
requirements this was in march 2020 i
applied for my license and i ended up
leaving the firm that i was at i was
actually moonlighting while i was
working at this firm and my client was
the owner of this franchise bakery that
was growing really really fast
and i'll make a video on this and they
had plans to expand all over the world
it's the
type of work that's not really glamorous
and but it's also not a lot of work
it's not as exciting because they kind
of have their own branding and they want
you to basically replicate like similar
designs for each location yeah it's
relatively easy it's good money
and you can work on your own time and
you know at that time like since i
finished all my requirements i just
wanted to take a break and think about
what i want to do next and so i booked a
yoga retreat in mexico
that i've been wanting to go on for a
really long time
and i was planning on doing the work
remotely and just like having a nice
time this is of course when cobit
happened and this was a pretty big hit
for my client and most of their projects
ended up getting cancelled and of course
my yoga retreat got cancelled as well at
that point i didn't have a job
and nobody was hiring at that time this
was really
scary for me because i kind of felt like
i'd made a humongous mistake like i quit
a good stable job at a good firm
and i just had a lot of anxiety
and um i also had a lot of time not
great combinations that's when i started
thinking about what could i do to make
money while using my skill sets and
interests of course my skill is
designing storytelling and being an
architect and at that time the youtube
algorithm probably because a lot of you
were having the same problems with me it
fed me this video by ali abdal talking
about how he was able to make money from
youtube that was when i made my first
video about the design process and if
you want to check it out i'll leave it
right here that's when i started my
youtube channel some of the videos
ended up getting a lot of traction and
the thing that eventually landed me
another job as an architect at another
firm and the lesson i learned from this
experience is that
when you don't know what to do
just go back to your foundations i say
this because when i was starting the
youtube channel the advice that was
given to me like over and over and over
again was to not make videos about
architecture and to make videos about
something else that would interest the
largest and widest broadest audience
possible when i really sat down and like
tried to list out the things that i was
interested in and the things that i was
good at i
just
couldn't
get myself to make videos about food or
fashion
or productivity so
i just made videos about design and
architecture and somehow it found an
audience and i think if you sit down and
look at your existing skills and your
interest you can have something that's
unique and you end up creating your own
niche i think in that first year of
kovid and i think this is probably a
pretty common experience that first year
i learned so much about myself like what
i liked and what i didn't like and what
my values were and what i was good at so
like i was saying before a couple months
into the pandemic in september of 2020 i
actually landed a job that specialized
in interior design tenant improvements
interior fit outs and i got brought on
as the architect to help like navigate
the building code and zoning bylaws and
you know all the legal stuff and also to
help out on some of their more complex
projects and professionally i thought
this was a great move for me
because you know i could start to build
a niche in this area um especially
because most of my previous projects had
been smaller projects and renovations
this was partially motivated by my fear
of running out of time and dying
i'm gonna get to a point where i you
know need to have kids and have a family
and where i can't focus on my career as
much and so i always thought it's better
to start building a niche early so
that was my thinking at the time but the
more i was there i kept feeling like
maybe i'd picked a specialty a little
too early in my career i'd only been
working in the field for like three four
years which is like totally an infant in
this industry and ultimately i i felt
like this was a time for me to be like
trying out different projects of
different scales and be learning from
more senior architects so that was a
massive
miscalculation on my part and after
about half a year i ended up leaving
that firm which was really hard because
they'd kind of made this role for me
there and
i built really good relationships with a
lot of the people and i just ended up
disappointing a lot of people there but
again this was another time when i
really learned a lot about myself first
that i really don't like to disappoint
people and i really don't like conflict
but i think the biggest lesson from all
of this is that you kind of just have to
be ruthless about saying no to things
that don't really align with your goals
and you will make miscalculations and
you will disappoint people along the way
and i think you just need to be okay
with that it was the same with my
previous firm actually it was very hard
for me to leave because i developed all
these good relationships with these
people but you know if you know it's not
the right fit for you anymore and that
your goals don't really align with what
other people want for you
then it's not really in anyone's
interest to have you around you just
have to be your own cheerleader and make
those hard choices because nobody is
really gonna do that for you if you can
identify and seek out exactly what you
want and are okay with disappointing
people from time to time in the end
you're gonna be happier in all aspects
of life and you're gonna be surrounded
by people who are happier so anyways i'm
at a different firm now i'm super super
happy with the work i'm doing and my
goals are aligned with what the firm's
able to offer but
even after getting my license i still
feel like a newbie in this field so i'll
leave you with my final lesson which is
be an active
lifelong learner the human species is
biologically hardwired to evolve so
growth is the key to a satisfying life
when i was making the decision on
whether i should stay or leave my last
firm i was essentially
deciding between do i want to niche down
and develop this thing that i already
kind of have an expertise in or
do i want to jump into something more
foreign and learn to work with different
types of buildings there's no right or
wrong answer and your answer might
change depending on where you are in
life um and in your career or in your
financial situation but i think no
matter what situation you're in there's
always an opportunity for learning and
growth should be one of the biggest
factors in your decision making anyways
i feel very very very lucky to have met
the right people who have helped me who
saw something in me but
you know that saying you make your own
luck as corny as that sounds i see a lot
of wisdom in that and to elaborate on
that a little bit more i really like the
saying you plant the seeds of your
serendipitous encounters and i just find
this concept so compelling especially
in ways that it's manifested in my life
like i just think it's a really nice way
of looking at the world that every
moment you could possibly meet someone
or see something that could have a
serious impact on your life i hope you
enjoyed this video and of course there's
tons of things that i didn't cover and
tons of questions that i didn't answer
but um i have an email newsletter where
i share some of my lessons and insights
so if you're interested you can sign up
at dannylea.com
newsletter i'll leave the link in the
description also let me know if you have
any questions in the comments
and i'll try to get to them asap if
you're interested in this life lesson
type videos
check out this video where i wrap up my
biggest lessons i learned from 2021
which was an insanely transformative
year for me alright thanks for watching
guys i'll see you in the next video bye
you